yeah welcome to this video five minute
game on them on icc yeah and its own
starts with 93 and feed a master from
the US yeah Halle Berry would be too bad
to play some chess against her some
other things well I guess it's not own
alright so let's see what we get here I
choose a king's indian set up and we
transpose to the Kings onion k black has
a multitude of setups i go for c 6 cm so
I don't know this line very very deeply
with some former teammates of mine i
played this so i have had this some
experience in watching watching the
games yeah whites mein moo sorry for now
or or h3 solely for it is i can on
exchange this Bishop now an alternative
would be here to play a 5 immediately
but I get rid of this sound this Bishop
first to check quickly is just a
provisional rating no it's just a
coincidence 2200 might be some sort of i
know the entry rating is 2000 I guess
all right doesn't matter so much okay
I'm exchange this Bishop which often has
a hard time finding some some useful
role and the question is if white plays
g55 or not actually it is Sam let's
think the current state of theory ism
that is better not to play this this d5
move but to UM but to wait to keep the
tension in the center yeah I don't like
that so much it seems to know what he's
doing okay here's an idea to play a 6b
five I can play six anyway which
see useful move also in case of him
playing d5 but then white has some some
more waiting moves available stuff like
a three or Queenie to don't know queen
bee three rookie one yes a multitude of
most if d5 I would take with the sea
pawns he takes and then try to play on
the C file so I'd like to to cd5 now
just because I am you have some exact
idea what what I'm doing after this I'm
not so sure if he just keeps the tension
what would be my idea in this case hmm
maybe be five then I doesn't know how to
tell another satirical idea could be
here to play Queen da to f8 and then
Bishop each six getting rid of the
bishop oh he's changed this is very
unusual ok yeah a dissolving thought to
be simply helpful for black because of
the weekly foursquare in this position
you might be able to play c5 this is may
be possible c5 immediately to prevent me
from getting anything on c5 myself my
dream scenario here would be a bishop fa
to c5 exchange this k bishop of Ages
useful anyway if I manage to exchange
the dark squared bishop and get in
something about Nazi 5v six then then
like simply has a very good position
I'm a bit bit irritated what he's doing
here but simply I'm very accommodating
from black I mean yeah II really should
avoid to trade the bishops now and it
doesn't maybe you wants player for okay
this is a possibility of course okay I
need to reposition the looks anyway you
can see a tensor useless on yet I try to
anticipate the NSF for move okay now i
want to take because before I is
threatened so we're about Quincy five
maybe winning winning a tempo 95 just
before I am okay maybe you recruit c5
yeah okay I think I win the temple yet
cannot exchange really this will help me
tremendously will tonight be 3 d 4 and
so on and so I wanted temple we need to
move the Queen again okay so is there
some way to to prevent before in c-5m
yeah well I can play a five what you
might have 94 which isn't so great in
itself but okay just keep it simple and
i also have not f82 v6 question should i
play a five now maybe maybe 85 here b5
is really bogus okay can play c5 but
then jan
of the AFL shouldn't be too bad for me
with the rook already them and I'll get
the light to to deform all you play some
Queen III you nighty to some some
passive move it's impossible Wow yeah
okay I cannot believe this but um okay
let's take it ism is trying to use his
pawns of this limb and I'm okay that's
three three pawns yeah from practical
point of view this isn't a bad idea
really it's not so so easy to do counter
okay I think I should should blunt this
Bishop so the Queen B 5 may be simply
threaten 25
okay this this can get really sharp now
if I take exchange and ruka look look
look check on the second-ranked time
learning the tricky okay but I don't
want to retreat the Queen okay play
something entirely different just a
small maybe this end f5 yeah we to speed
up also and so quite apparent okay then
not only six in now cover c7 they have
those threats against g3 can you to get
out of the pin
okay probably I need to take it okay now
i should get t7 yeah it's an end gamma
with Mona coldly is wrong but I can oops
I could have taken the Queen I can take
yeah I can take the poor now the alcaide
draw is suddenly a fair result hmm I
could have simply one on time of course
and yeah by taking take him taking the
Queen yeah okay but I had no time myself
yeah I wit game but this 95 was so once
was a nice nice touch him I mean I it's
certainly not working but in a blitz
came it it poses some problems and to
think he got got a pretty pretty decent
position yeah yeah I should play root K
to look a to f to some stuff like this I
thought I could play this later but now
it really gets gets a bit tricky yeah
the computer gives the smallest about
equal funny enough and now we can win
with Queen takes ph okay yeah now i'm ok
again we are very difficult very
difficult but ok so it's a nice touch
with 95 it's maybe maybe not though the
mathematically speaking computer like
speaking correct move but
it needs to see are two very unclear
play if I get 90 64 and I'm simply
better yeah thanks for watching